[Música]
ustedes los convocaron así que lo que
les voy a pedir es que ahora como
convocaron a los monstruos no me dejen
solo que se hagan cargo de haberlos
convocado con tanta claridad y con tanta
suficiencia
cuando yo era chico me crié parte de mi
infancia con mis abuelos mi abuelo se
llamaba arturo y mi abuela se llamaba
envidia me crié en el campo y en el
campo no había luz
un buen lugar para los monstruos
la vida del campo la pasé con mis
abuelos y con mi hermano se llamaba
alejandro
y la verdad que la vida del campo es una
vida llena de aventuras para un niño
el día era extraordinario todo el día
afuera andando a caballo corriendo
libremente pero había un momento del día
que no queríamos que llegue
la tarde de la tarde cita de los colores
de la tarde ya anunciaban que iba a
llegar un momento que no queríamos que
llegue
pero inexorablemente
como ustedes los convocaron llegaba la
noche
mi abuela después de cenar nos daba una
vela como esa
y nos decía bueno chicos a dormir y con
mi hermano teníamos que enfrentar una
galería larga nosotros dormíamos en la
habitación número tres en la tercera
enfrentamos una galería larga pero
encima lo tenemos que hacer como
sigilosamente porque al caminar con la
vela en la mano por la galería oscura
tenemos que ir cubriendo la vela para
que el aire de la galería no la pague
porque era la única herramienta que
teníamos para enfrentar la noche y con
ella los monstruos una vela
llegamos a la habitación nosotros a esa
altura no sabíamos que los seres humanos
nos podemos quedar dormidos contemplando
el fuego el fuego pero no una vela que
es distinto
llegábamos a la habitación poníamos la
vela arriba de la mesa de luz dormíamos
en una cama de dos plazas esas de campo
que tienen los elásticos que se hunde ni
que se hacen un pósito al medio y
entonces que habíamos los dos ahí
tapados con un rango de chulengo y la
vela solamente la vela era la única luz
que teníamos en la habitación
mi abuela si sabía lo del fuego y
entonces cuando nos veían la cama abría
la puerta sigilosamente y nos decía dos
palabras tres chicos la vela
y cuando nos decía chicos la vela
nosotros sabíamos que iban a llegar
ahora incluso de nuevo convocado por
ustedes los monstruos de la noche
entonces que hacíamos
nos abrazábamos
porque estábamos muertos de miedo y
saben cómo lo sabíamos porque como que
nos empezaban como a transpirar las
manos teníamos frío imagínense en el
campo las ramas de los árboles pegaban
en las chapas de zinc parece que los
monstruos también empezaban a hablar y
nosotros mirando la vela con mi hermano
nos pretendíamos hacer una teoría de la
luz empezábamos a buscar en esa vela
esos dibujos esos claroscuros que las
velas arman en las paredes y en los
objetos estábamos muertos de miedo ese
día fue la primera vez que me di cuenta
que éramos vulnerables
y tuvieron que pasar cuarenta y pico de
años cuarenta años específicamente para
que hoy yo esté parado aquí a
explicarles a contarles a compartirles
que estamos hechos de miedos
javier dijo recién que ahora había
perdido el miedo a construir una casa
pero había un miedo ahí
tenemos miedo a fracasar tenemos miedo
al futuro tenemos miedo a no ser amados
tenemos miedo a que publiquemos algo en
el facebook y nadie absolutamente nadie
nos ponga un like
y yo empiezo a transitar otro miedo
además de todos los que ya tengo
acumulados y que nacieron esa noche
oscura abrazado a mi hermano ese miedo
que empiezo a transitar es el miedo a
llegar a viejo
y a ustedes algunos están más cerca pero
muchos de ustedes están más lejos
también les va a pasar estamos hechos de
miedo y sin embargo así todos hemos
decidido afrontar el siglo 21 como uno
de los mayores desafíos de la humanidad
a pesar de todos los miedos hay una
cosita ahí en el fondo de la resiliencia
que nos hace humanos que nos hace seguir
adelante y afrontar todos los miedos
en estos miedos aparecen los monstruos
porque ustedes los convocaron
acá están algunos me di cuenta me di
cuenta sobre todo los que están acá en
la primera fila que no llamaban a los
monstruos yo los vi
[Música]
sin embargo otros y otros llamaron a los
monstruos nosotros nosotros los adultos
hemos creado estos monstruos de la noche
saben quiénes son esos monstruos
nuestros chicos los creamos nosotros
porque los dejamos solos los dejamos
solos a manos de la tecnología
y ahora les tenemos miedo
porque decimos este siglo 21 que estamos
viviendo este futuro que ya está acá nos
los están disputando y nosotros no era
que teníamos el poder para manejar esta
historia donde quedamos nosotros
nosotros seguimos siendo adultos que le
tememos al futuro a lo que va a pasar
mañana ahora sí nosotros que somos
simples mortales les tememos al futuro
imagínense lo que pasa cuando uno se
entera alguna vez que beethoven el más
grande músico de la historia de la
humanidad también fracasó el día después
que estrenó la novena sinfonía ustedes
saben que van gogh el más increíble
pintor que haya conocido yo por lo menos
no vendió nada más que un solo cuadro
que el futuro los condenó imagínense
si a ellos les ha costado construir el
futuro como nosotros no vamos a tener
miedo al futuro si estamos viviendo un
mundo que nunca en nuestra historia en
nuestra genética en nuestros ancestros
ha sido vivido
nosotros ya estamos habitando este mundo
nuevo porque lo denominamos con palabras
el otro día me enteré que ha sido una
acción pero que no sabía cómo se llamaba
entraba internet navegaba un rato iba en
busca de un libro que necesitaba para
mis clases de la universidad y terminaba
30 minutos después buscando un lugar en
el mundo en una página de turismo que
por siete días no tenga viento dijo que
estoy haciendo dónde quedó mi concepto
de sociología que tenía que buscar y
terminó ahí mirando una playa
paradisíaca de cancún donde las palmeras
no se mueven el miércoles el jueves me
pasó esto imagínense
y ahí me enteré que hay una palabra que
denomina ya esté presente que ya dejó de
ser futuro y se llama serendipia que es
ese proceso que hacemos cada uno de
nosotros cuando ingresamos a internet a
buscar algo pero terminamos 40 minutos
después
buscando y encontrando otra cosa
absolutamente distinta somos como
errantes en la web y generamos ese
proceso de serendipia hay otra palabra
que ya la usamos y que marca este tiempo
esa palabra es la orografía saben lo que
es la orografía
si dicen alumnos se ve que ya están
investigando eso es la ortografía pero
propuesta para poder discernir por qué
escribimos tan mal en las redes
no palabras que no existían en la
historia de la humanidad hoy las estudia
la orografía pero hay un montón de
ejemplos más hace 20 años yo me
sorprendí el primer día que escuché la
palabra frisar
lo que expresar era la acción de poner
algo al freezer claro pero yo me había
criado con una heladera y entonces me
encontré en esa instancia generando una
acción que no conocía pero poniéndole
palabras y cuando nosotros le ponemos
palabras a las cosas lo que nos damos
cuenta es que hay un tiempo que ya
estamos viviendo hay una que es muy
conocida que es juglar
google es un fenómeno absolutamente
novedoso porque google nació en el 98 no
hace tanto tiempo y sin embargo nosotros
ya usamos palabras para poder decir una
acción que hay que imagínense a una
persona que no conoce está dinámica
cotidiana digital google le parece
absolutamente extraño y la última hay
muchas otras la última es creo yo la más
desesperante de todas que es la apcob ya
sabe lo que es la upg obvia la upg obvia
empieza a ocurrir desde las 7 de la
tarde en adelante y es el momento en el
que las notificaciones de las app nos
transforman en unos seres absolutamente
vulnerables miro el teléfono a las siete
y media de la tarde y tengo 40 45
mensajes de los grupos de whatsapp a los
que pertenezco que ya sé que no voy a
contestar y entonces me siento
absolutamente agobiado porque la
tecnología me empieza a marcar la cancha
este tiempo que vivimos es un tiempo de
números si yo me paro acá y me presento
lo que debería decir que soy
el número 22 millones 0 08 408 y tendría
que presumir que con ese número ustedes
entiendan que esa es mi identidad porque
este que estoy recitando es mi documento
nacional de identidad
miren si yo pongo en este mismo momento
la palabra miedo en el buscador de
google google necesita solamente 062
segundos para poder decirme que en el
mundo hay 192 millones de páginas que
citan la palabra miedo necesita menos de
un segundo en este mundo que está
colonizado por los números es un mundo
superficial
por eso navegamos quien navega por
debajo de la superficie que hacemos
durante todo el día cada vez más horas
lo que hacemos es navegar navegamos por
la superficie porque abajo está
prohibido saben lo que está debajo la
ahdippe web
ya dar web ahí donde están los monstruos
que ahora vamos a volver a convocar esos
monstruos saben cómo se llaman
millenials centennial es generación z
post bieber nerds son todos monstruos
que nosotros mismos hemos creado este
mundo tecnológico es un mundo que nunca
en la historia de la humanidad hemos
vivido esto que venimos viviendo en el
siglo 21 es absolutamente inédito la
imprenta nació en el siglo mitad del
siglo 15 y después vino el telégrafo la
televisión la radio en el 98 en 1998
google y en 2004 facebook 2005 youtube
2009 whatsapp y 2010
instagram ha revolucionado de una forma
absolutamente inédita porque nuestra
vida cotidiana hoy está definida
determinada por los algoritmos de
repente un amigo que tenía en facebook
desapareció
salió de facebook no alguien me dice que
hay un algoritmo de facebook es decir un
poder oculto invisible poderoso que hizo
desaparecer a mi amigo y que me obligó a
tener que ir a buscarlo de nuevo en la
esquina donde siempre nos encontrábamos
porque ya no lo veo más en facebook
porque él dice que un algoritmo lo
oculto en ese mundo binario de cero y
uno saben que hay una luz como la de la
vela mía cuando era chiquito esa luz es
un algoritmo especial que yo quiero que
ustedes no se olviden nunca en su vida
es el algoritmo de 6 12 saben que es el
bc y 12 un mundo nuevo que tenemos la
chance extraordinaria de construir a ojo
ese mundo tiene algunas características
especiales que debemos cumplir para
poder evitarlo y si usted y ustedes
quieren lo pueden hacer la primera
condición es apagar las notificaciones
del teléfono después de las 7 de la
tarde
quieren entrar a ese mundo apaguen las
notificaciones pónganse un rato en nuevo
avión saben lo que es ponerse en modo
avión no apagar el teléfono para tomar
un vuelo
y ponerse en modo avión para como decía
charlie poder volar de la cama al living
o de sillón en sillón almohadón az o por
medio para quedarse un rato de risa por
fuera de las notificaciones es pensar un
mundo que está armado en función al
bienestar tecnológico el bienestar
tecnológico significa poder construir
porque ustedes lo pueden hacer un mundo
donde los seres humanos tomemos el poder
por sobre la tecnología pero lo tenemos
que decidir todos porque si no lo
decidimos la tecnología automáticamente
se nos impone ese mundo es el mundo del
bienestar tiene una sola condición para
que pueda ser habitados saben que tienen
que tener para entrar ahí tienen que
tener miedo
no les digo que tengan el miedo que yo
tenía cuando era chico lo que les estoy
diciendo es que tengan miedo que bajen
los brazos que bajen la guardia que se
dejen abrazar que cuenten que digan la
persona que dice que tiene miedo no es
más débil no es menor es una persona que
está siendo un poco más humana si
quieren venir a este planeta hermoso
están todos invitados lo único que les
pido a cambio es que tengan miedo saben
por qué porque es la única chance si
ustedes dicen que tienen miedo es la
única chance que le estamos dando a
estos monstruitos que nosotros mismos
construimos porque los dejamos solos con
la tecnología de que no nos suelte en la
mano no con el sentido de que nos digan
la tengo clara y este mundo es mi mundo
sino por el sentido de poder pensar
juntos que un nuevo siglo y un nuevo
mundo solamente se puede vivir si somos
humanos y vamos de la mano muchas
gracias
ah
[Música]